a lot of people lost health care
coverage during the pandemic and still
don't have the insurance they need
especially if they're facing a
life-threatening disease denise valdez
tells us about a local free resource for
breast cancer patients in today's buddy
check reports
[Music]
it's saved my life it saved my life i
don't i don't honestly know where i
would be without it bess norris is
midway through her breast cancer
treatment and grateful to the engelstadt
foundation red rose program for bringing
her this far not having to worry about
can i pay for my next doctors can i pay
for my next visit is this next surgery
covered that alone takes a ginormous
stress off of you red rose stands for
responsible early detection the program
through dignity health saint rose
dominican serves uninsured under insured
and undocumented clients we also provide
ultrasounds biopsies
mammograms full spectrum of breast
cancer
screenings for women and men at no cost
i was improved within a week i think i
was in my first surgery maybe 10 days
later
i'm now going on my fourth surgery
norris is one of more than 7 thousand
patients helped with screenings clinical
breast exams mammograms ultrasounds
surgical consultations and biopsies for
her the program has been a lifeline it's
just so much
and you try to stay healthy and positive
and you have all these things in life to
be grateful for and
then it's just one surgery after another
and your body's just tired
norris will undergo a double mastectomy
this week it's her fourth surgery in
eight weeks to try and beat breast
cancer and she's had a team supporting
her all the way i wouldn't i wouldn't be
here without red rose i wouldn't nothing
would even be possible without them
denise valdez live local now to see if
you qualify contact red rose program at
st rose dominican the number is on your
screen at 702-620-7858
you can get a preventative exam totally
free with no need for medical insurance
or proof of residency bilingual services
are also available